Hello Freak bitches are doing the same kind of things that had gotten like you
would do.
That's what they think.
Oh yeah.
But that's not the case.
What is the big difference between body
builders allergic as a high purpose each 40 do you have high reputations in
night?
You know they eat different and they take other things different to get very
big.
And then we don't want to get vague or just like we want to stay in the smallest
weight class we can and get as strong as it was the same.
Big and strong,
strong,
strong.
So we just want to be strong.
So everything we do is not to build larger muscle.
Like I've worked with track people,
mostly girls.
We don't want to put 10 pounds,
actually bodyweight,
almost 10 pounds of extra weight that it had to overcome.
Gravity run down a track,
right?
So we keep keep your body weight to a minimum,
you know the muscle mass.
We just want to make it strong.
You don't have to get bigger to be shown.
That's confusing to a lot of people.
Cause a lot of people think of big muscles meaning stronger and that's the only
way to get stronger.
But I've seen some people and power lifting competitions,
it just lift insane amounts of weight and they're not that big.
Well how is that possible?
But muscle type,
you know,
you're always talking about you.
I've always mentioned you a few times.
You talk about like a wooly as [inaudible].
He runs out of gas real quick.
Who?
Tyrone?
Tyron Woodley.
Yeah.
He has the same,
they've got a pretty,
pretty much the same amount of muscle mass.
He just has very fast,
which muscle and our guy you're talking about an endorsed may have board slow
twitch muscle and then so that that guy,
that's why he can fight five rounds and Tyrone,
where to start from where out somewhere in the second round.
Well it's also because a guy like Tyron is capable of putting out so much
energy,
like the way he can attack us and move so fast.
It's like having a 500 horsepower engine versus having a 400 horsepower.
One's going to just use [inaudible]
gaps.
Right.
Well just fashion.
That's what you've got sprinters and you've got marathon runners and it looked
totally different.
Yeah.
And so when someone looks at a bodybuilder and they see this guy just covered in
muscles,
they assume that guy would be able to lift a ton of weights.
But for the most part,
those guys can't lift nearly as much weight as a guy like you can.
No,
that's,
that's crazy to people.
Like that doesn't even make sense.
Well,
like a lot of things are crazy.
People do,
don't,
aren't in and note came up.
What were Michigan,
what about this anabolic steroids?
Do you,
does it frustrate you?
The disc lack of understanding the general public has about this stuff?
Absolutely.
Yo,
you ever,
you ever look at the Olympics?
Um,
we look at are weight lifters,
Olympic weight lifters.
We don't go to the Olympics.
I hope we never do hope.
I live to never get any letters.
They were sending the worst.
It's if there's ever,
but they said our,
when the team,
it's pretty bad.
We can't get a guy on the 18 all right.
And they're just not very good.
You look at our women gymnastics people,
they're extremely strong.
They blew her out of the water.
You go to China,
they're male weight lifters and female archery ministry muscular and he killed
her body.
But your gym's look pathetic.
It's because they're all in different systems.
You know,
there you got better coaches and,
and better systems that take stuff.
So
American doesn't have good Olympic
power lifters,
Olympic weightlifters,
weightlifters.
We rolled the world pout of Jews in this country.
America went into twos are not very good.
They're not now terrible.
Really?
No,
I did not know that.
There was one girl what got a bronze in Olympic.
One girl got a bronze.
We and my sport,
there's 12 male way classes.
Uh,
we hold seven of the total records.
My Jim Holtz too.
And,
and women,
there's 10 weight classes.
America holds nine of the 10 and my Jim holds five.
I have the strongest male power lifter have ever lived,
period.
And the best and the strongest female.
It'll vary.
Same Gym.
Now what about shit late?
Those strongest men contests?
Oh,
well there's strong as guys,
but that's a different thing entirely as well.
It's another defense.
Like boxing is different than him in May.
Yeah.
More,
you know,
more ties different in boxing.
He never said,
I'm going to say a Moitai guy that's going to win a world boxing championships
and vice versa.
Well,
I think it has happened.
Um,
ty was,
what the fuck is his name?
Oh,
there was a kid though.
I mean,
I could pick gold metal and Thailand.
Pakia I think you shouldn't have your key.
Might've been a,
um,
white tie champions that right?
Oh,
Chris Algae area.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was a,
a kickboxing champion.
One time to put work has a name.
So what's the fuck is his name?
Samsung,
I forget his name,
but there was the guy that,
he's the guy that John Claude van Damme was always supposed to fight.
John Claude van Damme pretends is going to have a fight.
It's going to have a kickboxing fight with,
this is Thai guy.
But that guy won a world title as a Meu tie fighter and as a boxer.
But that's,
that's pretty rare,
but I agree with you.
But now like what would be the difference?
See,
like if you see like if you got a guy coming to you that wanted to win,
like a strongest man competition,
that seems like something that would be right up your alley because you're so
good at preparing fighters and understanding the different demands of different
sports.
My friend and Finland's names car,
he's got four guys and that Jim had debt of over 900 and they're all strong man
and he does well.
He trains a lot of Straw man.
All right.
I'm not in to that,
but told Tom and I that the one thing in each sprint would thousand pound
wheelbarrows,
thousand pounds on the rhubarb.
We do a lot of wheelbarrow work and all of a sudden he carry heavy yoke.
So that's two of the primary things.
You get them to be strong in.
What's a yoke?
A Yoga thing,
putting me back and you walk around with it like if you walked around,
we do a normal amount of walking loop.
What bars with a badge and change hanging off such an unstable cause.
That's what you have to be.
You'll,
you've got to be stable and unstable environment.
So they walk a half a mile stuff like,
I don't know,
basketball or he gets his strong.
Is that why you like wheelbarrows?
Cause it's almost like a dead lift that you've got to kind of walk with going in
price or we'll get more typewriter.
Don't thought that really helped us up as plum color to clinch.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Um,
so did you come up with the idea of using wheel barrels for Gwar Berlin ninth
1990 and it's something that looked to you
like a good unstable platform for that and it builds up your registry manager,
you're building up your back and,
and grew up you he got to have a grip.
Right.
So and you know,
most [inaudible] guys got great grips anyhow,
but it builds up grip and it builds up all your muscles and your walking.
See My,
you know,
a lot of guys do strength and conditioning.
I believe it's got to be combined.
You don't have that much time because fighting is a treatment,
a skill.
You need all your,
I mean the world's strongest man.
And he the dam,
the MMA champion,
Huh?
Right.
So I believe you got to straight then Kadesia st time.
That's why we do so much outside walking.
We're doing heavy.
I,
I carry not objects walking.
She'll work conditioning and strength training.